[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar shining a spotlight on
cytomegalovirus diagnostics focus on
improving outcomes for mothers and
babies
i am cassie saltman of labroots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
to create awareness and support for the
cytomegalovirus international awareness
month today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by core diagnostics at abbott
to learn more visit corelaboratory.abit
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker
professor sebastian hans professor of
virology
limoge university and hospital professor
hans you may now begin your presentation
thank you for the invitation to present
a spotlight on situ michael virus
diagnostic and
our strategy of diagnosis and guidelines
i'm working
in the department of bacteriology
biology
and in the national reference center for
airbase viruses in limoge france
some disclosure statement
the learning objective is to describe
the clinical spectrum and outcomes of
congenital
cmb infections to realize the importance
of screening and diagnosis
and understanding the role of diagnostic
testing and recognize opportunities for
prevention management and therap and
some word about therapeutic strategy
so to resume
very quickly uh the
uh
role of cytomel gala virus uh during
pregnancy
uh
in general like as you know air situ
miguel virus belongs to the herpes vir
viridi family
which are characterized
by a latency phase after primary
infection and the ability to reactivate
sometimes
a rare feature reinfection with another
strain
called happen
satomir virus is a virus very largely
diffused in
worldwide and the zero prevalence vary
from fifty percent in high income
countries to
hundred percent in low-income countries
so
we will
see after the consequence of this
variability
it is
actually the first cause of congenital
viral infections since rubella
vaccination with 0.3 to 2 of births
every year
for example i took the last data of
france with
more than
700
000 births
last year
you can imagine that between
2
200 and
40 000 infected neonates uh could
be
infected with with the situa virus
the
this virus
can be transmitted by different way we
can
we have to
[Music]
to separate
both uh
way
but most essential way by uh
the community way first and second the
care link way
considering the community way
of
transmission
this way is
essential for
in case of
congenitals in the infection
and
we
will uh
we will see different origin of
transmission uh depending from the age
of contamination
for the newborn
there could be
infected during pregnancy in the
continental infection
or
infected
by a perinatal exposure or during
breastfeeding
during childhood
children
are exposed are exposed to saliva and
urine of other young children and there
is a very important transmission of
child to child
and of child to
adults
for teenagers and adults
the
main source of contamination is the
exposition of to young
children and
also sexual transmission
for killing
contamination way it's completely
different naturally
and
the different way are blood product
allograft from the same vessel or
positive donor and sperm donation
with artificial insemination from cmv
positive donor
may
as you can see in this different way
which are very multiple but close
contact is
in general
the
main elements
to
lead to the transmission
in a study that we published recently we
have studied
potential source one of the main
potential source of same day
contamination
we analyzed the saliva of
children
which are in a daycare center in france
we collected more than
1000
saliva
in a different
day care center
on
distributed on all the
french territory
as you can see globally
40
of
children
were
cmv positive in saliva
so they can
be a source of
same way contamination with
different with a different proportion
considering the different
category of age
when you look at
the other graph
showing the different viral load
measured in saliva
we can note that
the level of excretion is
high between four and five log in
general with extreme until uh
nine log
copy per milliliter of saliva
so
this study
confirmed that
these young children
are a
very important source of contamination
essentially for young adults and
sometimes for a young woman who are
pregnant
this word uh data
of uh
cmv infection same vco prevalence and
congenital infection
where was collected
by uh manicle in uh 2014
and uh show that
uh
the
as i said uh the therapy balance rate
among women of reproductive age is very
different between
countries
and
the there is no
direct correlation between the level of
zero prevalence and the level of birth
prevalence of congenital zinc infection
that's to say that transmission
can occur
even in case of high sero prevalence in
women of reproductive age not only in a
seronegative
woman
when
we look at the pathophysiology of same
big continental infection
it can occur
after primary infection
with
the highest level of transmission
between 30 and 40 percent
but
it can also cure
during rec re infection or reactivation
rain uh ray infection with another
strain or reactivation with
the
horn
strain of the of the pregnant woman
for
this case
the level of transmission
is probably
less than one percent but
very
little information very few sorry very
few information are available about the
rate of transmission
following reinfection or reactivation
and what is important
is that
in both cases
we have we can observe at
delivery symptomatic newborns
in
10 to 15 persons
and asymptomatic newborns
in the majority of case more than 85
but
whatever the
presence of symptoms or not
new bonds could have sql
naturally
symptomatic newborns have
are
secretly in
90 percent of case
but asymptomatic newborns could have
secretly in five to ten percent of cases
so it's important to understand this
point the different
uh
secret that we can observe after uh
congenitalizing the infection are
neurological disorders uh
with microcephaly periventricular
calcification
and other
disorder of
central nervous system
we can observe also sensor neuronal
hearing loss
unilateral or bilateral that is the
most frequent
complication of same infection
and also ocular damage like
choreotinitis
as we can supposed uh
with the
distribution of
the level of continuity of infection
in correlation with the data of zero
prevalence
non-primary maternal infection explain
approximately
fifty percent of congenital
infection in european countries
in this slide we have two
studies performed
the first in france and the second
in
finland
and for the
study performed in france by marian
laurez
who belonged to the national reference
center of air press viruses in france
she screened more than 11 000 neonates
she found a maternal cell prevalence of
50 60
and a 7 fiction at birth of
of
0.
37 percent
but when we look at the origin of the
same bean fiction
uh
they
they found
that
52 percent
followed a maternal primary infection
and
48 percent follow the maternal
non-primary infection
and
in the same
pro with the same profile of
contamination the finland study
with
about
20 000 neonates
found the maternal cell prevalence
of
72 percent
and save the infection at birth of
0.2 percent
and the distribution of
origin
of um
infection was a primary maternal
infection
in
47
and
a non-primary infection in 53 so
the the data are very similar between
both 2d uh
both large 2d on
more than uh
uh
30
40 000 neonates in global
and
the
transmission
could occur
in
non-inceronegative
pregnant woman and in sero-positive
pregnant women
another point very important to uh to
know either that the risk of
transmission varies during pregnancy
as uh
you can observe in this figure
the transmission
to the fetus increase
from
the
first trimester to the
third trimester but
in contrary symptomatic neonates are
more frequent
in
first trimester and we have
no symptomatic neonates in
first trimester contamination
so
the major risk
is in first trimester for primary
infection
because it's a time of growth of
central nervous system
a recent review published by chatakis
in 2020
gives that the the data
the precise data
of the transmission rate in
the different period per reconception
first trimester second trimester on
third trimester with the
increasing risk of transmission but
in contrary a decrease in fatal insult
if fetus is infected
between the periconception first
trimester period and then
very very low risk
near zero
in the second and first trimester
so it is important to know
this point for the advice to
the infected woman
for non-primary infection
the link
is unknown between gestational age and
risk of sickering but
it is likely to be the same
as primary infection
that's to say first trimester
remain the
major time
of risk
for
securely in
neonates
when can we make a diagnosis
or screening
for
congenital symptoms
during pregnancy
we can check for uh
same being fiction with serology
in front of
in front of infectious syndrome
or after igm detection
whatever the trimester
in the second and first trimester
we
can
suppose that
the same infection is occurred
with when you detect ultrasound
abnormalities
after pregnant pregnancy at birth
the detection of them b
can be performed
and
if
you
have children with hearing loss
you can during childhood make a
retrospective diagnosis of congenital
same being fiction
today
is a question about systematic or
targeted screening
i want to
define precisely
what is the screening
with the different criteria defined by
the who
systematic
correspond to a detection in all women
versus
targeted
it's a detection
of infection in only in a woman at risk
of exposure
and as you can understand targeted
training is very difficult
uh in practice to perform
for cmv infection
because
clinical symptoms are not specific
until now no randomized control trills
has evaluated the value of systematic or
targeted screening for civil infection
in pregnancy
in france
screening is performed
outside the
official recommendation
in
almost 25 percent of pregnant women
more frequently in paris area and less
in other french regions
why the screening was not
recommended by french health authorities
until
2020
it was said that the benefits are very
limited because
no therapeutic option was available
for infected woman
but
we will see that
after
2020
a
year of publication of
very interesting study that showed the
benefit of
vlasic review treatment
we can
ask the question of
cmv screening during pregnancy
however we have already
favorable opinions from the french
national medicine academy and the
national college of gynecologists
obstetricians
which tools
could we have for
diagnosis during pregnancy
the
diagnosis of maternal primary infection
is
easy when you detect a zero conversion
of igg
but
for
the
definition of several competitors
seroconversion
needs to have
two serum
per serum negative and second operation
of igg
and often
in a pregnant woman we have is we have
not
always a
different serum to observe the
apparition or uh
of operation of igg
so it could be interesting
to
recover serum prior to pregnancy
compare both serum
the detection of igm
have
a good sensitivity between
80 and 90 and good very good specificity
and
control of igg on previous serum should
be performed is
if igm and igg are positive
on the test
and third
assay
is the ability of igg if
the profile
is
positive in igg and positive in igm or
if you have
ultrasound abnormalities with positive
igg
concerning the diagnosis of ray
infection and reactivation
until now no test is available
so it's very difficult to
make this diagnosis
because some reinfection reactivation
have no igm
and the
igg theater
sometimes didn't differ
between both seraph
concerning the
igdm the absence of them doesn't rule
out the diagnosis if there are
suggestive abnormalities
in
u.s
how to interpret positive igm
in recent primary infection
it's
easy because
igm are
always observed
in this situation
but
igm are often
positive
in other
situations
first
the persistence of igm
could be until
six months
so
and depending on the technique used
so sometimes it's
impossibility
and so it is impossible to date
a primary infection with the igm results
in case of secondary infection
sometimes
the
igm
are positive again
for infection or reactivation
we found igm positive in non-specific
polyclonal stimulation of the immune
system and sometimes in crosstrek cross
reactivity with ebv in particular
so igm positivity should be interpreted
with caution
and should be completed with
igg
avidity
concerning ability of type g
immunoglobulins
these assay
was developed because
it exists a maturation of the immune
response after the infection
that's to say an increasing of the
antigen antibody affinity
the test measures the degree of specific
dissociation of the human complex by the
action of the of a denaturing agent like
urea
then you calculate the ratio between ig
teter without urea and
on igg theta with urea
and the interpretation uh
i give an example here but
be careful
the
cutoff
of interpretation varies according to
the test used
less
for example less
30 percent it corresponds to an
infection let that three months old and
over
60 percent 70 sorry it's an infection
older than three months
this test can eliminate with the
sensitivity of 89 to 100 of primary
infection if performed before the second
trimester of pregnancy
so it is very interesting to test women
during the first trimester
because after the second trimester
if you detect
high heavy dt we you can not exclude
a contamination during the first
trimester
containing the performance is of
cmb igg abilities say
i just
take this
figure from maria gracia rivelo
published in
2010
to show that uh
in this very interesting study
the performance of cmv test abdt tests
are very
different
from one test to another
so it is important that
you
uh
follow a woman
with
the same test
and that
the biologists
that use
navidity assay
know very well the limit of
its test
of his
sorry the limit of his test
uh
to uh
interpret
uh
correctly the results
and in this
second study published
three year after crystal volufelu showed
that
the
new cutoff value of vedas igg
were better adapted to to the evolution
of
the ability
of following zero conversion
after maternal infection it is
important to make the diagnosis of fatal
infection because maternal fatal
transmission is not systematic
following a maternal infection
the main indication is ultrasound
abnormalities
and
or infection during the first trimester
after amniocentesis
the ammunitic feed
is analyzed by pc here to detect the
viral load the same way by our load
it is very it is essential to
have the good timing for
amniocentesis performing
the
this
dysfunction
should not be done before
21 22 weeks of a mineral
and
at least
six
to eight weeks after their zero
commercial
in other cases
you can
have false negative results
comparing the by the
level of fire same way viral load
we
now
have
noticed the notice that
the level of fire load has no prognostic
value
and then a birth
after for different indication
like maternal primary infection during
pregnancy igm positive ultrasound
abnormalities
the
or for diagnosis confirmation
we can detect the virus
on
virus on urines or on saliva
before we
isolated the virus
and now only pcr is performed in this
indication
the sampling should be performed before
15th day of life
because beyond that
perinatal infection cannot be excluded
through breastfeeding close contact or
other situation
the difference is very important because
perinatal infection
have no
risk of malformation and
the risk of
there is a new risk of serious infection
if
it's a premature neonates
more and more pcr on saliva
was
chosen because
the main advantage is the simpler
sampling
but be careful
there could be a risk of contamination
but then they excreted in the milk in
case of breast feeding
in this case
it needs to be confirmed by pesai on
urine
what are the performance of neonatal
screening in saliva
for
industry of marijuana
she uh found that
cemve denavir load in saliva
contaminate contaminated by maternal cmv
dena is very low as you can see with the
median bioload of 2.2
versus a median viral load
for
neonates with
a real con same vector digital infection
of
7.6
during childhood uh
when the children
is suspected of a continental infection
in front of earring loss
the we can make a retrospective
diagnosis
with the only sample they can
systematically systematically adverse in
all newborns the good record or dry blue
spot
sample at the d0
and we perform pcr on dbs
[Music]
after dnr extraction
and with parental consent
this is the only test that
can
allow to perform
a
diagnosis of congenital
cmp infection
during childhood
so the strategy of screening proposed in
limbo hospital
from
2020
is now to
detect igg and igm at first second and
third trimester of pregnancy and then
add delivery
in case of igm positive we perform igg
ability and
pcr and serum
the objective is to detect
naturally primary infection but also
very variation in igg tito or igm
detection
in several positive women that could be
suggestive of re infection or
reactivation
the different algorithm that we propose
the
for
this first slide is in
case of
igm positive and igg negative to
perform a second test
two weeks after
with pcr and theology
and if
igg are
negative again and pcr negative we can
conclude to a false positive or cross
if igg
become
positive we perform iggy ability if
additives awake it
we can
conclude to a zero conversion
and performance management according to
the trimester pregnancy
when both tests are positive igm and igg
we perform high degradation and the pcr
if the ability is weak
and the pether positive it corresponds
to a recent infection with viral
replication if the
ability is weak with the pesa negative
it is a recent infection without by
replication
in case of high humidity if pessim is
negative it corresponds to infection uh
overalls humans and if pcr is positive
it could correspond to reactivation or
rain fiction
and in case of high humidity it could
be very interesting to retrieve previous
serum
for example
with a
pine theorem collected for other tests
like beta hcc or
toxoplasma follow a follow-up
then you can check zero g
two weeks after if av dt and pcr were
not diagnostics and retrieve a previous
serum
at
a time
of early pregnancy or before pregnancy
naturally in case of infection during
pregnancy whatever primary or secondary
it requests
advice from a prenatal diagnostic
diagnosis center
and in on this slide it sees the
algorithm proposed after systematic
screening during pregnancy in the
national reference center air press
virus in limbo hospital
if there is a
primaries in the infection in the first
trimester or in the very conceptional
period we
proposed a treatment with valencia via
high gram per day
until amnesian daisies
amnesia synthesis
is then performed uh following the
previous recommendation and if pcr
assembly
is negative
we can reassert
reisterate the patient
and the risk of fatal infection is less
than eight percent the risk of long-term
sequelae is around zero percent
uh for uh
or checking the
the fetus
we propose an mri of fetal brain at
32 weeks
and then at delivery
check of the presence of virus in urine
or saliva
for
the
same the positive pcr we
consider maternal therapy until delivery
with valencia be a gram per day
we consider fatal blood sampling at 20
weeks for plastic and same median level
we perform ultrasound every two weeks
until delivery and then hemorrhage of
fatal brain at
32 weeks
if there is no symptoms or extra
cerebral symptoms or mild several
symptoms
we
check only the presence of virus at
birth
after delivery and if there is several
several symptoms we discussed the
possibility of a termination of
pregnancy
and
last
algorithm uh
in the
case of evocation of the diagnosis of
same infection maternal theology
whatever the term
in case of seroconversion
let's say a primary infection at second
or first trimester
we perform interest around every month
an mri at
20 32 weeks and detection of uh symbiont
pcr
with special urine or saliva birth
in case of seroconversion suspected
or impossible to date or secondary
infection
we perform ultrasound every month until
delivery pithier on urine saliva
at birth and mri only if there is
ultrasound
abnormalities
no termination of pregnancy are proposed
in the absence of sin or ultra
on ultrasound or mri
so that way we present the last
uh first result of ccmv screening in
limbo hospital because we have not the
last that are
completely analyzed
before 2020 we perform only targeted
diagnosis
and
we
have
around one per one uh zero g per woman
the several prevalence in this
population was
53
after
uh 2020 we start the systematic
screening
uh but it was at the beginning of
the covet pandemic so
all the women were not completely
screened in this period and we observed
a
median of 1.8
serum per woman
the cell prevalence was
55.1 percent
in this population
what impact on congenital diagnosis
so in
2019
with targeted diagnosis we examined 11ks
in prenatal diagnosis center we detect
six primary
so
0.15
of
delivery and two neonates
infected so 0.05
of congenital infection
after the
systematic screening
starting
we examined uh
29 cases in prenatal diagnosis diagnosis
center
with
16 same infection so
three times more
14
primary infection two secondary
and four neonates
with the congenital infection
or 0.11 persons
so to conclude
this
presentation
we can say that
the diagnosis of congenital infection
could be difficult
essentially for interpretation of the
time of infection and as you
as i said
and as you can
see in the different slide
the
main
time of
risk in the first trimester so it is
very important to
have the
try to
to define the time of infection
second point reinfection and
reactivation are potential source of
congenital cmb
so it's very difficult now because no
tools are
very well defined for efficient
diagnosis of such situation
but
we
have to keep in mind that
such women could transmit
cmv to the fetus
theological screening could limit the
number of infected neonates by
initiating balanciclovia treatment at
first trimester of pregnancy and allow
earlier a more effective diagnosis of
fatal damage and also earlier neonatal
management so
two important advantage
and finally
it is
very interesting to
collect previous serum to estimate the
kinetic of infection
and
we have to keep in mind that
even if the theorem has not
were not collected for cmv diagnosis
first sometimes we can
check for other serum
collected for other diagnosis of
toxoplasma follow-up for for example in
france or
for
pregnancy diagnosis
at the beginning of the pregnancy
i want to acknowledge
about society for the organization of
this
webinar
and the
national reference center
for airplace viruses team
in the limous teaching hospital
with the professor sofia the director of
the
nrc the technicians of our center and
the technician of the unit of infectious
theology and naturally the dr perrin
kosmaso
which is our
main
[Music]
correspondent
in the obstetric and gene ecology team
of mother children hospital in limoge
thank you professor hunts for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question
is what are the neuropsychiatric
complications in the newborn who has cmv
infection in childhood adolescence and
adulthood
thank you for this
very interesting
question
um
i can say that the most frequent
complication
of congenital symp infection is
sensor neuronal
in hearing loss sorry
that can be unilateral or bilateral
but we
it is important to to know that hearing
loss can be sometimes detected
late
only when the infants enter the school
if no diagnosis is done at birth
so it is important to
to be careful to to this complication to
this complication with the most frequent
for more severe damage
we can cite development developmental
and motor delay
and uh
vision loss also
the most severe complication is
cerebral palsy
[Music]
normal life uh for for such
children and very
uh
important organizations for parents for
for example
[Music]
i think it's some
most frequent complication that we can
cite
okay
wonderful next question
do cmv infection rates go up after the
first child if older siblings are in
daycare and bring it home etc
uh yes it's also a good question uh
that we
because in practice in our routine
activity uh it is the very freaking
cases case um
the
the pregnant woman uh
with
her they are negative at the first
pregnancy
are frequently impacted by same
infection during the second pregnancy
because
they have their first infants
that
can be infected
for example in dk center or
in the first year of school
and then
bring it at home and transmit the buyers
to
the prank to their pregnant mothers
so it's a very classical
case of transmission
that we observe very
very frag
very frequently yes
okay
why are pregnant others not routinely
screened for cmv
um
[Music]
the
question
is the source of
a lot of debate
because
until 2020 we
had no
efficient therapeutic strategies to
propose to women
with a primary infection during
pregnancy
so
the risk of
screening
woman
pregnant woman
was to increase the stress of such women
during pregnancy and
probably
that were a fear of health authorities
increase the number of termination of
pregnancy
because if women are stressed and
don't want to
to have an infected
fetus or
with a stress to to
to observe after
severe complication that at birth
there was a risk of termination of an
increasing number of
termination of pregnancy
moreover
a screening strategy
must be cost effective for government
and if you have no treatment for
decreasing the number of infected
neonates
its
logic that the strategy cannot be cost
effective but
since 2020
primary infection
during the first trimester as i said can
be treated with
valaciclovir
that
is the
an inhibitor of
sito miguel virus and air pests and
other airplanes viruses
for example herpes simplex virus
that allow to decrease
the risk of fetus contamination
and this molecule
can be given
to pregnant women
because it's always the case for herpes
complex virus infections
and the
in 2020
there was a
very good study that showed
the benefit of
treatment
of a woman treatment
in the first
trimester of
pregnancy
okay so now
it could be interesting to
to start the screening of uh thing being
fiction
all right
next question um does the virus make
cognitive function degenerate
yes
uh
if but
the the difficulties for uh for the tmv
is contrary to
rubella rubella virus for example
um the cmv is not responsible
in
each case of infection for uh
not responsible for
for complications
as i say as i show in a slide
the
most
most of the
congenital cmv infection
don't lead to
complication or
not severe complication
so
it's
that
that's why it is very
uh
difficult to
uh to explain
to pregnant women uh
what
will be the
future of
the uh
of the
pregnancy and the future of the baby
uh that
could be infected but
with those without complication but the
fear of uh to
to detect complication
is always the present
but
the virus can
can
infect
neural system and
be responsible for for severe legion
okay
it looks like we have time for one more
question
the question is what is the
effectiveness of cytomegalovirus vaccine
a very interesting question because we
are waiting for a long time for vaccine
for simply vaccine and
there was a lot of studies uh from the
last century
uh and uh until the the last uh studies
[Music]
in the last year but
until now
the different uh simply vaccine
studied or
proposed in different today
it is a
don't didn't show
[Music]
effectiveness
against cmv congenital infection
but
thanks to the
mrna
technology
a new vaccine is
on study
actually
and
we will see with this
new mrna
cmv vaccine if the
if the efficient efficiency
will be better
but
until now the different vaccine
was developed on different
with different model and different
technology like
recombinant protein or
with the gb of the situation virus
or
live attenuated vaccine also
in the first
trials
but
no had a very significant efficiency
but with the last
vaccine proposed by
moderna
with the mrna
this vaccine contains
different
emery now
to develop
a human response against different
antigen
the pentameter complex and the gb so we
have some hope
to
and we we are waiting for the
for the first uh clinical results of
this vaccine because until now
it was
not
we were
no
not truly showed a very
good efficiency
okay thank you professor hans do you
have any final comments for our audience
uh
i
for to conclude this decision um
i i want to have that
cmv screening
is probably a good opportunity to reduce
the
the number of infected neonates
and that we
hope uh that
the
uh
both
um
that both um solution uh
same way screening and probably a
vaccine
could
decrease the burden of
this infection
thank you again thank you for the
organizer
yeah
yeah
um thank you for your time in your
important research we also would like to
thank lap roots and our sponsor abbott
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
you